hey guys Pete here another episode of
mr. robot is come and gone and this will
be my recap and review for season 2
episode 6 there's a lot to talk about so
let's jump right into it the episode
starts out in the standard-definition
sitcom starring the outer some family
based sometime in the 90s the whole
family is together and mr. robot tells
us that they are going on a road trip
Elliot is having a hard time
understanding what's going on and
everyone else seems to ignore its
concerns it's definitely a cool way to
start the episode and we get a return of
some characters we haven't seen it for a
while
Gideon who plays a cop just to get
killed all over again and Tyrell who
plays a version of himself who happens
to be tied up in the trunk for as long
as the sequence is we don't learn that
much that is actually important towards
what is going on in reality as mr. robot
feeds sitcom-style responses to Elliot
each time he expresses his concerns
about where they are and what's going on
we catch clues and Darlene's gameboy and
in the rearview mirror of the car of
what's going on in the real world it
turns out that this is happening
concurrently with the massive beating
Ray's goons are laying on Elliot from
the end of the last episode there are a
lot of funny parts including Elliot's
mom knocking out Darlene a cameo from
Alf who eventually runs over Gideon on
the highway the family laughs about the
fact that mr. robot is dying of cancer
as he coughs up blood and generally a
bunch of cheesy quips with a laugh track
to punctuate all the drama oh and the
theme song is pretty good too if you
didn't know swords go back and check
them out it's worth a read listen for
sure at the end of the sequence we
arrive at the hospital or mr. robot
tells Elliot he was just trying to help
him put it all in the rearview as Payne
Lee as possible he says that after the
beating they gave him at least they
brought him to the hospital he sends
Elliot back to the real world and says
now the worst is behind you Elliot wakes
up wheezing and appears to be in a lot
of pain he looks worse from the where
and the hospital room is definitely odd
looking we see lone stars there and ray
tells Elliot a story about Maxine his
dog as soon as he wakes up the story
boils down to how Maxine was the type of
dog that lived as her own operator and
that he thought maybe she never knew she
belonged to someone we find out she got
heartworms and in her sickness needed
ray to feed her and give her
the medicine he says for the first time
in her life she realized that she
continued to breathe because someone
allowed it that she had a master the
realization is what killed her he says
before the parasites got the chance the
obvious implication here is that Eliot
now belongs to Rey and his criminal
organization
he leaves Eliot to rest but not before
telling him that they had big days ahead
and work to do at this point raised
early interactions with Eliot seem like
nothing more than manipulation he
learned his weaknesses and used them to
gain and gain his trust if you think
back to how things went down it's hard
to imagine that there is any real
connection between the two I think the
scene where Rey is with Artie in his
house you know his family's terrified
they're watching is a good indication
his feel about him being more of a
positive reinforcement guy as opposed to
Lone Star's way of dealing thing with
things it seems clear that Eliot is
trapped with Rey at this point and I
would guess that it will take extreme
measures for him to break free as we cut
away from the hospital we hear Alf on
the TV across the hall saying democracy
is dead back at the squat in Madame
executioners place we find trenton and
darlene watching a news clip we find out
that the attack Don was involved with in
China is topping the news and that this
is going to make the hacking the FBI a
lot harder since they'll be on high
alert
Darleen still thinks they can do it and
wants to move forward with using angela
to plant the FEM to solid eCourse she's
having trouble learning how to implement
implement the scripts necessary though
and they don't have much time because we
learned that she saw an interoffice
email saying that the FBI was leaving he
Corp the next day Mobley's they're
trying to teach her and Angela says
she'll be able to do it when he asked
Darlene about the femtocell she says
that Cisco's got it handled and that
he'll be there so don't worry about it
Cisco's at the library and an unknown
Asian man comes in and throws him a
backpack with what he has been waiting
for he asked him what he did to the
femtocell and the guy puts him in his
place two guys wearing dark army masks
come up and hold him while the other guy
tells him that he's a foot soldier and
foot soldiers only do one thing they
follow orders they definitely don't ask
questions he takes out a hypodermic
needle that as far as I can tell doesn't
have anything in it he just sticks the
needle in the Cisco's finger and then
brain
that often walks away I think this is
just a painful reminder of who's in
charge but if you have any other ideas
of what is happening here let me know in
the comment to me it just looked like he
wanted to do something super painful to
him and it looked like it worked
damas in her boss's office and he tells
her that they are recommending that she
take four weeks off for psych leave
after the shootout in China she argues
with him that you know she can't leave
the investigation for a month and
refuses to do so their exchange is
pretty telling when we find out how the
shootout shootout ended Dom points out
that they went to investigate the hack
and this whole thing was just a tactic
designed to get them to leave her
interpretation is spot-on and it's
largely based on the fact that the
shooters were there to cause a
disruption and more importantly to leave
nothing behind
we saw how quickly the first shooter
that she had clipped with you know
decided to shoot himself rather than
continuing to shoot at her we also
learned that the second shooter did the
same even though he had her pinned down
that we looking we saw that at the end
of the episode and he could have easily
took her out it looked like anyways it
was a suicide mission that achieved its
goal it got the FBI FBI out of China and
with no clues left behind made it hard
to link the whole thing to the dark army
and easy to pin on someone else in this
case they mentioned a lower-level
separatist group Phillip prices in his
office on the phone with the congressman
or someone like that and the guy tells
him that he can't push through a bailout
price insists that this needs to happen
and tells him to get it done the person
on the other end of the phone doesn't
sound hopeful in light of the events
that just went down in Beijing and price
reminds him that if it doesn't happen
the country will go bankrupt his
assistant walks in to tell him that he
can't get Minister Jang price says of
course basically calls whiterose a
[ __ ] and insists that his
assistant keep trying until he gets
through he then asked him where his car
is and the assistant tells him that he
can't get the car can't get through
because of all the protesters outside at
this he tells him to call the police and
have him send over as many people that
are as necessary to get him out of the
building basically turned in Mobley are
watching a rattled Angela work on her
part of the plan while she starts in
with the positive affirmations again as
she's working she starts saying to
herself my success is assured over and
over
everything seems to be in order and we
get a tense scene when Cisco drops by to
drop off the gear with a bandage on his
hand
Angela immediately recognizes him as the
seedy guy from season 1 and can't hide
her surprise as he talks to Darlene
Darlene asks what's going on but after a
long drawn-out look Angela says nothing
I thought I recognized your friend but I
don't
Cisco never says anything at all and
Darlene lets it go after giving him a
suspicious look tom is back at the
bodega where we first met her buying
some 5-hour energies and talking to the
same clerk we catch the east equine
signs behind him again by the Bitcoin
signs and also see that there is no one
else in the store besides her we learned
that to $50 a day limit on withdrawals
has killed his business and that he's
going to have to close up shop Dom tries
to cheer him up but this seem seems to
be there just to point out how bad
things are getting for the little guy in
the days after the hack we catch Darlene
in disguise and she uses some social
engineering to get herself into a hotel
room we assume this is next to the II
Corps headquarters and she's on you know
the 23rd floor which is the same floor
that the FBI is working on Annie quarter
her scheme works and she gets herself in
and sets up shop angela is in her
cubicle and we see that she puts her
real phone into the drawer at her desk
and pulls out a burner that Darlene
gives her call log she heads to the
elevator to put their plan into action
she enters the 23rd floor moves past
some agents on their way to lunch and
goes right into the bathroom and there
she goes right into a stall her first
attempt at running the script doesn't
work so she calls Darlene and Mobley as
she's talking to them someone comes into
the bathroom which raises the tension
the scene has some cool like almost
frantic music in the background and the
the camera shots are handheld which I
don't know it's pretty exciting I'd like
the actual scene weekend when she when
the woman who's in the bathroom goes out
the door we see a glimpse of an agent
that tried to say hide Angela on her way
in and it's pretty noticeable that he's
lurking outside Mobley tells Angela what
she needs to fix and everything starts
working as soon as she comes out of the
bathroom the agent is there waiting
turns out he wanted to ask her out and
he isn't really trying to take no for
answer as Darlene urges her to get rid
of him and they spoof a call from his
mom that he ends up ignored anyways he
starts to ask what is she doing on this
restricted floor she flips things around
agrees to have lunch with him and seems
to get him out of her hair as he walks
off presumably to call his mom back this
could lead to something of where he
realizes she doesn't actually call but
then again we might not never see this
guy again
Angela finds where she needs to set up
the femtocell and follows through
Darlene's direction after she's done she
tells her to wipe off her fingerprints
and she does but I'm not exactly sure
she did a good job I might be looking
too hard at it but whenever I rewatched
it looked like she might have missed the
box in the back where she plugged in the
ethernet cable again this might not be
anything and it might not matter anyways
everything looks good at first but as
Angela's walking out Darlene loses the
signal we see that it started to pull
data from what looked like phone related
files but the Wi-Fi connection drops out
Darlene tells her that she needs to get
to a terminal to bring things back up
and Angela is not happy about it
Darlene reminds her that she needs to
you know needs this connection to remove
the footage of Angela snooping around on
a restricted floor she tells her to get
to her cubicle and Angela takes off she
runs into some agents on her way out
which causes her to take a turn and use
the stairs at first I didn't think much
about this but when I went back and
watched again I noticed that that
actually could be Dom standing right
there we go back to the hospital to
Elliot who's it seems like we haven't
seen forever at this point he tells us
about masters and how some people need
to be controlled I would really like to
add the clip here because it's kind of a
key part of the episode but since I had
so much trouble with using video clips
with mr. robot videos in the past I just
I'm just gonna explain it to you so he's
basically talking about how every
relationship is a power struggle it
relates back to the sitcom dream
sequence in the beginning in that he
says that sometimes the best course of
action is to ride shotgun and keep your
eyes on the road ahead and just hope
that it leads somewhere somewhere you
need to go
he knows he's trapped and he doesn't
have a way out so you know he's gonna
have to bide his time until he's healed
and he gets a guess
just as he's finishing the thought the
goons come back in and abduct him once
again and I gotta say how they managed
to scoop him up and carry him out of the
hospital I have no idea just like I had
no idea how they were able to grab him
screen hit you know grab his screaming
ass from his mom's place and beat him
into like an inch of his life right
outside without anyone noticing
something going on with this is there a
reason the diner that he eats at in the
hospital he's in have like this dingy
dreamlike appearance and he's is that
anything more than just a way of setting
the tone I just don't know either way
they take him off and from there we go
back to Angela's cubicle she has her
headphones on and Darlene is giving her
instructions walking her through what
she needs to do step by step on the
screen it looks like she's two letters
away from finishing when someone says
her name right away we recognize this is
Dom's voice and things are getting real
she excuses herself telling Angela that
she didn't realize she was on a call she
hates when people do that to her and
that she can wait for her to finish the
situation seems pretty dire but of
course it's a cliffhanger and we don't
find out how it ends
Elliot is dumped I'm ceremoniously on
the floor but looks like a basement Lone
Star gives him a once-over and then
leaves the room at first my thought was
that like he maybe he's in the bottom
the basement of the hospital but then I
noticed there's a water heater in in the
corner and that made me start to wonder
if this is the same room where Ray put
Maxine while she was dying he mentioned
she had a water heater for a neighbor so
could be the same one being dumped on
the floor does not help Elliot's health
and we see he is clearly struggling mr.
robot comes in and basically apologizes
for not explaining what was going on in
the sitcom scene we find out that all he
was really trying to do was keep him
from feeling the pain that was being
dished out during the beating Elliot
forces himself up grabs on to him to
stay there thanks him and then gives him
a real hug with tears in his eyes this
is a this is basically the opposite of
how he reacts the first time when mister
robot hugs him you know right before he
went into the hospital you know if I
think it probably reflects Elliot
realizing that in this situation or you
know situations like this that he does
actually have been used and he does
actually need mr. robot we in the
episode with the flashback to what
it was a was still a you know young kid
his father has picked him up from school
after what looks like you know situation
where he got into a fight
he's asked him a bunch of questions and
Elliot's just staying quiet during the
drive he tells Elliot about losing his
job from from Eve Court from leaving
work too many times when Elliot asked
why he was leaving so much he tells him
that he was going to the doctor and we
realized that this is when Elliot learns
about his father's cancer he also tells
him about a computer store that he's
gonna open and they go on their way down
there
Elliot is asked if he can work there and
mr. robot says sure he's got a job for
him right now and lets him know that he
can name the store himself and when they
pull up he asked him not to tell his mom
about what they just talked about and
not to basically not to tell her about
the fact that he has cancer so this was
all a pretty good episode and I was
happy with that it didn't in with the
multiple cliffhangers like the last
episode did we do have one though and
for those of us that watched a trailer
for the next episode we get a little
more information about what Dom's up to
and him Angeles cubicle but no clear
idea of what's gonna happen do you guys
think she finished typing in what
Darlene told her do you think she got it
back online I mean all she had to do was
type the word up like a space in the
word up and it was all in the line above
it exactly the same so I don't know it's
inconclusive for sure because you don't
hear the keyboard sound his dogs talking
to her so I'm interesting what you guys
think only it's in a pretty tough spot
where he won't be much help but we do
know that Raina is expecting them put
him back on a tournament all for work
you know as soon as he's healthy enough
to get down to business so we are over
the hump officially and you know we're
in the back stretch of the season I
expected all the characters will be
getting to where they're going in the
next couple of episodes the standoff
between DOM and Angela seems to show
that not both of them will be able to
come away from the unscathed and Elliot
and race situation is pretty much a
mirror image just with some different
things at stake so something's brewing
so how do you think our new characters
are gonna end up in the end I mean like
I said they're they're in direct
conflict with you know the main
characters of the show Ecore is also in
a bind but at this point everyone else
is actually feeling the pain
we have an example of the same type of
situation in the real world from you
know the financial crisis of 2008 only
here the five nine hack has made it a
lot harder for the government to tack to
take the taxpayers money and bail the
banks out my guess about why this is is
that since F Society succeeded in
destroying the backups and effectively
wiping out the debt you know Ecore can't
collect the money from the debts which
would be their way of paying you know
the people back with their own money
yeah somebody if you know it you know if
you have a little bit more of an idea of
why this is such a tough spot and feel
free to leave that in the comments as
well still got no Tyrrell other than him
being tied up guy in the trunk and we
didn't get any Johanna at all this
episode so her story is still where it
was at you know one thing I noticed I
realized at the end of this episode I
was actually rooting for DOM and that
you know that shouldn't really be the
case since her basic purpose is to take
out our protagonist and all the people
that he cares about so I'm excited for
where the next episode is gonna take us
and you know so let me let me know in
the comments what you guys think
what's Ray's endgame was Tyrell really
outside Joe in this apartment and you
know what's gonna happen when micros
finally answers prices call there's a
lot of stuff to think about before the
next episode and you know keep in mind I
try to respond to all the comments in
the first day or so after uploading the
video after that it gets a little bit
hard to keep up with it so post away and
I'll try to get back to you please like
the video if you found that interesting
and be sure to subscribe to my channel
I'm on a pretty regular schedule with
mr. robot now so you'll want to know
whenever the new one comes out thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon